[Applaus]
start in einer höhe von 2.500 57 metern
die tour die die skiprofis benedikt
maier und markus jeder gemacht haben ist
auch für freestyle kölner durchaus
außergewöhnlich
die bilder von ihrer fahrt wurden jetzt
veröffentlicht
die beiden extremsportler rasten den
höchsten berg pass italiens den stelvio
pass oder stilfserjoch in die tiefe
dabei überquerten sie springend mehrere
straßen zusätzliche schwierigkeit
richtig viel schnee hatten sie bei ihrem
abenteuer nicht auf ihrer fahrt nutzten
sie dabei alle gegenstände die ihnen in
die quere kam
nach angaben der organisatoren hat es
eine solche abfahrt bisher noch nicht
gegeben meyer und eder hatten sich
monatelang darauf vorbereitet
[Applaus]